c'est un moineau il est dans la forêt
et tout d'un coup ils vont un éléphant
il regarde l'éléphant il fait
je te veux
je te veux je te veux c'est un coup de
foudre je te veux je te veux je te veux
je veux te [__] je veux te [__] je
vais te [__] et les fois il fait
arrête
regarde-toi regarde-moi tout nous sépare
c'est impossible je m'en fous je m'en
fous ça coûte fou je veux te [__] je
vais te [__] au bout d'un moment les
feuilles normalement c'est bon bah vas-y
au moineau
et au-dessus il y a un chimpanzé qui est
là allongé sur une branche entrain de
manger une noix de coco et il fait je
rêve je vois un moineau qui nique un
éléphant c'est extraordinaire j'ai
jamais vu ça
le chimpanzé que il lâche la noix de
coco elle tombe la tête de l'éléphant et
ils font
ça [__]
[Applaudissements]